salut aujourd'hui je suis allé voir un
super pièce au théâtre bossa martens est
prête moi ta femme écrit il jouer avec
sacha judasko c'est moi et je sois mais
sur recruit vous regarde ça m'énerve je
sens que j'ai ensuite fabien est ce que
tu as ton téléphone portable avec toi ah
oui est-ce que tu as un code de
verrouillage pour désactiver quoi pour
la vraie info web tu gardes ton
téléphone dans la poche pour le moment
tout ce que je veux savoir s'il était
verrouillée je vais déjà essayer de
trouver des numéros vous êtes dans
l'ordre et dans le désordre dans le cas
qui m'a dit c'est ton code c'est ce sont
des chiffres s'est qualifié le cacher
puisque tu en as ou qui peut mettre
plusieurs chiffres je veux te demander
de penser peut-être au premier chef
d'accord tu penses au premier chef me
regarde dans les yeux qu'il cherche pas
de l'aîné lundi je veux dire des choses
tu peux répondre your mom est dans la
tête jamais car balisé en fait par
exemple souvent les codes commence par
un parce que les gens entre les dates de
naissance ont beau plus simple mais
c'est assez fréquent aussi pour nous
juste que c'est qu'on se souvienne de la
gestuelle de nombreuses et bien qu'on
ait une forme géométrique
on dit par exemple sur un triangle ou
des ailes du voyage et on voit tout de
suite qu'il ya des choses qui marchent
ce qui est intéressant c'est de le voir
aussi ici pense qu'on serait plus sur un
espèce de truc comme ça plus si ça te
parle ou pas dans la gestuelle j'ai un
sentiment d'aller retour ouais ouais
coude non style cool s'améliore déjà
pense avoir raison sûrement un an
premier numéro du coup je mets 10 y
aller retour et serait dans ces cas là
enfin et en troisième position
une autre maman
manquerez le 2 et le 4 mai siens d'aller
retour c'est à dire que sa tête deux
fois le même est ce que je peux voir ton
téléphone s'il faut faire je tente et ça
on aime cette caméra s'est déverrouillé
gc je sais que les sévices des gens qui
vous reçoit des messages mais tu vas
voir donc si tu es fan de cuisine sans
pilote des verrous et c'est que c'est
bon ils le seront avant fois ci j'ai bon
et si vous le ferez apparaître est bien
la fille et c'est bon c'est bon coin
n'ont pas dit comment tu fais bordel
porter pourquoi 13 13
ce que c'est je suis fan de lelouch
c'est mon chiffre cependant bernanke et
je suis content d'avoir trouvé ton code
et en plus de ça pour faire grand
plaisir à ceux qui regardent la vidéo
juste en dessous de cette vidéo dans les
commentaires je met le numéro de sacha
comme ça si vous voulez l'appeler pour
parler de votre côté vous pouvez y a pas
à dire elle vous c'est quoi personne n'a
fait aucun prix vont aborder la pièce
prête moi ta femme c'est une tueriie ça
fait trois fois que je la vois en toi on
peut le dire c'est pourquoi parce que le
sénat il est énorme fierté très drôle
qui s'est vraiment bien joué c'est vrai
tant que maman des peurs
très drôle c'est bien joué et le
scénario est tellement pertinent
tellement intéressant qu'on a envie de
revoir la pièce plusieurs fois pour ne
rien rater
je vous recommande vivement mais
vraiment d'aller la voir même plus le
mentaliste n'avez pas deviné la fin
c'est pour vous dire
samara 1re même temps bien évidemment
mais toi tu es un moment on a envie de
tout péter rées gal mais moi je mets
d'ailleurs on sait quoi il est mon
numéro
moi je voulais c'est sur l'adresse où
vous allez chez lui lui péter la gueule
pour moi merci vous très bientôt et
rendez vous demain à 17 heures pour le
prochain mentale blog ciao